Philips line really went all out with a
roller coaster and live music it's a
spectacle that almost makes his new
clothing collection beside the point the
whole event costs pleines some one and a
half million euros doesn't so hon Titus
a fun it's part of the labels success we
think we understand what this dream
industry wants and we give it to them
the spectacle call me to see that's how
it was back in Caesars day that's gave
me he always said give the people bread
and circuses that's what we do get
tonight we give them bread and circuses
he gave me in potter's field Philip line
really likes to lay it on thick snake
skin goat skin and a dose of glitter his
love of rhinestones has earned him a
reputation as a king of bling
the mcafee feeling hunt up i do a lot by
hand all these studs which you could say
are what gibbet ling are all hand
applied to a leather belt how find him
if I'm Lita googling is in all of us
especially girls every little girl once
dreamed of being a princess plan were
watching my princesses are flying has
also upped his recognition value with
celebrity appearances he hired
supermodel Naomi Campbell in 2014 Grace
Jones sang up one of his shows in 2013
rapper Snoop Dogg performed at the milan
menswear show in january
and hotel heiress paris hilton showed up
clad all in Philip line I think he's
such an amazing designer I really loved
his brand it's always so gorgeous and it
stands out and just I love the style
gold digger is his line of leather
covered furniture line started out in
furniture design he earned his first
million at 24 with his luxury dog bed
that became the seed money for his
fashion business for the past five years
the 37 year old has presented his
collections in Milan from his start as
an outsider he's now a mainstay he's a
bow I was always skeptical but he's come
a long way he has great designs and
course glitz and glamour TV shows that
fashion is fun a big event smaller
spaces on the event could no tsuki until
a lip line serves the clientele that
like to show off a bit the EBD develop
line each finna destroy does this dunya
man it's great that someone is setting
out from Germany to conquer the world
that's exactly what Philip line is doing
finds our line has already opened his
second boutique in Milan's fashion
district the trademark in all of his
stores is a skull made of Swarovski
crystals the prices are in the upper
luxury segment the target group is young
people who want to stand out from the
crowd
speaking sent via the new generation v
that's why we're the new generation
we're a brand that i would say captures
the zeitgeist onions because i'm close
to the consumer I also see myself as a
consumer and I designed for the client
design it food in quinton now with new
flagship stores in new york singapore
los angeles philip lion is expanding
rapidly he's posting sales of more than
200 million euros yearly thanks to
aggressive marketing that's for coal
from yet at the end of the day what do
we do we sell emotions dreams that's
what luxury brands do if a call from
join the new winter collection is almost
restrained in black and white with a
hint of elegance now line and his team
of three hundred are planning a line of
sunglasses
the sauna might really something I
wouldn't say it's a never-ending task
but once you start there's really no end
that's the nice thing people ask what's
your goal your dreams see you the
journey is the goal in Vegas the sealed
the fun really starts after the show and
everyone can ride the roller coaster
it's far from the last big dream for the
german designer he's planning to have
100 shops around the world by the end of
the year